so how we haven't quote here from author
David Sedaris okay Pizza french boys
from brainyquote okay that's where I get
my source time I've been keeping a diary
for 33 years or so and I write it every
morning most of its just whining but
every so often there will be something I
can use later a joke a description of
quote it's an invaluable aid when it
comes to winning arguments and such as
like that's not what you said on
februari of 1996 something like that so
you've mentioned in many interviews that
you've been a big david sedaris fan and
of course CU chi is based on a chapter
right from yeah what suppose um what is
it about his right it's so fascinating
what is about him it's funny that you
brought up his diary because he does
like when he says diary and when I think
diary I think like what just before
going to bed like you know like by
candlelight like right he keeps a
notepad on him and whenever anything
like strikes him is something memorable
he'll write it down and of the few years
I've known him there's been like one or
two maybe two or three times where I
like I said something when he's like
laughed and ran it down and those are
like the proudest moments in my life
because you know if you're right and
even during when he saw the film at the
premiere he was like writing notes I
think that's a his way of sort of
appreciating something you know it's a
sort of May gonna make a note of it and
he but I don't need his work it's funny
because I for me I'd this story why I
like his work and why I liked the story
for a movie they're somewhat overlap but
at the same time that I like them in
different ways i think his voice is
unique and relatable at the same time
and i think that's really hard to pull
off and i think he set off a big long
generation on still ongoing generation
through this american life and through
his work with ira like of a whole group
of people that can speak personally you
know of essayists really i think he
helped popularize that and a lot of ways
not to say it didn't exist before of
course it's existed forever SAS but i
think the humor and the angle and sort
of the the approach he took has inspired
a lot of people and for me I feel like
the kind of life anecdotes tells fit
themselves or at least this one did in
particular to a movie it doesn't they're
smaller they're a little i was
interested in that to make a movie that
wasn't trying to solve the world's
problems
an hour and a half you know that it's an
they had a mission but was still
relatable and funny but complex and
those are the kind of things i wish i
could write myself so that someone else
already did and i got the opportunity to
adapt that was um you know better than
if i could have generated it myself do
you have a similar voice as he said you
wish you sorta kind of you know I I wish
for it I don't think I'm his clever you
know I don't think I'm I tried to in
writing it I tried to you know because
there's you know there's punch lines in
it that are my own there's a couple I'm
particularly proud of they get laughs
and I hope they fit into that tone you
know I tried to adopt it but I don't
think i could write and i don't think i
could write about myself like he writes
about himself you know I don't like I
was honest with myself see is which is
amazing how how he could be so you know
you get his van he just goes away and he
can write about things so honestly about
how he feels about something even if it
reflects kind of badly on him you know
which I which I really appreciate you
know the not to not have to UM you know
glorify herself I found that interesting
and I wanted to bring that into the
character I thought well maybe he
shouldn't it's a younger version of him
so I thought maybe he shouldn't be so
likable maybe he hasn't absorbed that
self-awareness yet and maybe this movie
sort of about the process of getting
there when you'd mentioned in Prior
interviews that you've driven and you've
done things like you know pay for
expensive tickets to go see him yeah
what were some of the highlights of
hearing him speak um you know for me it
was I first saw him I was in college and
I drove a few hours to orlando see him
speak and that was the first time I'd
same speaking there's something he's or
that he's one of the rare people that I
would like encourage people to almost
like listen to the audiobook is almost
sometimes even better than his written
word because his voice in his an
inflection there's something so unique
about it and there's also like who other
there's rarely any other writer in the
world that you can go see and sit in a
sold-out theater of like thousands to
watch read like that doesn't really
exist so it does for bands and musicians
and and say and even filmmakers to a
certain extent but not not really
writers so there's something about the
communal aspect of like going to see him
read and but
he brings to it and his shows usually
half him reading his material and he'll
try out new material and and so you get
a little sense of his process and the
other half is his show or like q and A's
where he pulls out his diary and kind of
goes their anecdotes they connect to
what people talk about and I don't know
he's just immensely entertaining like
there's something about that and I
didn't necessarily think the movie would
capture that you know he doesn't he's
not a writer in the movie he doesn't
read it doesn't you know that's not
really part of my intention but it is
part of my admiration for and what's one
quote from you as the dares that that
really song had to the one I mean
there's there's tons what's the author's
one there's something about syphilis
it's really funny I can't remember it
right I can't believe in forgetting her
it's all what I always quote but were
the one thing I did love that I thought
about a lot when I approached him and
wanted to make this into a movie he
talked about in an article he wrote
about the movie that was supposed to get
made out of me talk pretty one day I'm
back around 99 or 2000 and he eventually
decided that gets doing and it was Wayne
wing was going to direct it and there's
a written script for it and I've even
read it it was kind of surreal and
statements so different than my movie
ever was strangely I think the woman who
wrote it had a film in competition at
something SS here also so I didn't get a
chance to meet her but the world's
aligned in a weird way but she but the
the but he read he wrote about the
experience of it be me being turned into
a film and he went to go see you can
count on me with his sister and
afterward she was if you think they're
gonna make me fat in the movie I think
this what she said and then he said this
great quote that encapsulated everything
I think how he feels about the film or a
film getting made was he said I realized
my fear wasn't that they'd get me and my
family wrong my favors they'd get us
right and um I think there was something
so sincere about that I think so many
people would like jump at the
opportunity to like have their life made
into a movie you know I mean you meet
people every day we're like my life
sorry to be so interesting and and I
what I really respected about him was
that he was so like no it's not what am
I gonna get from that what is my what am
I gonna put my family through on that
and my approach to him was one to really
respect that ideal which is I want to
take this specific story you know I
didn't want to make out David Sedaris
you necessarily I wanted to take of
course that was part of the appeal
because I admire him so much but it was
this story you know was I felt it stood
on its own I felt it could stand on its
own away from his identity his family's
our characters and had their not
portrayed on screen um so you know you
have all these elements that I thought
would lend him to to appreciating that
you know and he did and his sort of to
me has sort of what he communicated to
me was go do what you need like make
your own movie you know let go do what
you want to do with it and he didn't
really influence it or want to influence
it he's not really interested in the
film he's a loves films but he's not
interested in the filmmaking process and
so I really took that to heart that
quote of his you know just sort of ran
with it and said okay I'm making a movie
that he happens to have written I'm not
necessarily I can't be indebted he
didn't want me to be indebted to his
identity or how he looked her how he
talks so I wasn't going to be so I
didn't cast them and it looks like him I
didn't tell him to act to his voice I
specifically told him to not really
watch him or try to mimic him or
anything like that I wanted the movie to
sort of be as much of my identity as it
would be David's so that's a long
incidents quote but what it's like
what's the difference between I'll look
it up I'll look it up I'll look it up
and tell you is that something like the
difference between and syphilis in
the dictionary camera but it is it's
really it's like my favorite quote of
his but anyways you're looking for
sympathy you'll find it between and
syphilis in the dictionary that's what I
was wondering it in one of our favorite
documentaries my big break my Tony
Sierra someone was interviewed and says
that you know most people in LA get
their big break they either aren't ready
for it or they don't realize it when it
happens can you look back on a time when
something was presented to you and it
seemed pretty miniscule at the time and
it was
life-changing that's a really good
question i don't know i think i'd like
to imagine that still may be ahead of me
you know in a lot of ways i can not to
say that of course i'm like if the
opportunities I've had it been like
incredible but I still feel like I've
been gladly and I if the rest of my
career goes like this I'd be happy like
working kind of under the radar for a
bit you know I've kind of always had to
try to find my own way to get these
films made you know I've always always
come together in some really sort of
strange untraditional way after like
three years or people telling me no like
both my movies have been that path and
so I feel like I've had to have it to
find it and build it for myself which
I've been happy to but I also but I
don't I haven't had like an accidental
thing yet you know I haven't had that
sort of like where I made something I
didn't think people are gonna see a ton
of people saw it you know as it hasn't
really been that yeah yeah but maybe it
has and I just don't realize it you know
i mean i think i think my first full
maybe is an indication of that like it
didn't it didn't get into Sundance
didn't get into South by Southwest I
didn't get into Tribeca didn't get into
I mean any of the major US festivals and
it felt like it was made totally
disappear you know it kind of felt like
I made this thing i'm proud of it i feel
like it's good i feel like i can stand
by it but like no one is gonna play it
anywhere and and then we got you know we
got an opportunity to screen at sinha
vegas which doesn't exist anymore but at
the time was notable you know enough to
get the movie on the radar and then and
then the movie ended up getting to
Spirit Award nomination so it ended up
building to something you know so I
think as opposed to maybe something
being like a snapping point or like a
big break or like this big opportunity
it's just happening I think it's
happening very slowly and I'm working
really hard for it and I hope that like
I said if I if I keep on making movies
the same way i've been making them and i
keep on falling under the radar like I'm
fine with that to me I just want to make
movies I don't wanna you know as long as
each to each film I feel like lends
itself the opportunity to get to make
the next one so that's that's what I'm
hoping for you know I don't know if I'll
ever be like a big big break like that
but I mean I've been getting into
Sundance is and I think in a weird way
maybe not getting to Sundance was like
it gave me a lot of perspective a lot of
preciation for when I did get to play
there
I've had been my first time I think I
would've been thrilled but I think it
would have maybe I wouldn't have
understand stood how hard it can really
be to get to play a movie there you know
and just and a lot of people i know just
because you played one movie there
doesn't mean your next one's necessarily
gonna play their you know and the other
way around so there's not there's no
guarantee and i think i went in with
that appreciation and so to said okay
hey I'm really I felt really lucky you
know I really I felt like I didn't feel
like I paid my dues with my first movie
I got an opportunity to now I just felt
like I got a chance to screen it there
and this particular movie appealed to
them in a specific way and um and that's
great and whether ever hopefully get a
chance to play another movie there but
if not I did have that one experience
which i always wanted so well going back
to the someone to watch you um award how
much pressure did you feel after that
because I'm sure it's a great feeling
it's a lady but then there's also this
this new pressure that I've got to
follow up with something wonderful and
and socio gee it's funny because I
remember we were in negotiations with
David for the rights when I won that so
it was strange because it was all these
precedent reasons like what are you
doing that someone to watch what are you
doing and I couldn't talk about it yet
because it's I think it was just super
would have been I would have loved to
have but um it would have been almost
preempt it would been way too
pre-emptive you know until something
signed I feel like it's not it's not
respectful to talk about it but
everywhere at the time feeling like it
felt good because I had this dream thing
like at the timing felt so I felt that
was probably like one of the high
moments of like my life like I had this
I won this award which is surreal and
did did great for me it helped it was
that I used that money to pay for the
option which I would have never been
able to afford on my own otherwise and
then I had my next thing and in some
ways that was a mistake and not a
mistake like what for me that what it
was I went okay i have my next thing and
this was what I gonna make and because
this was David and he gave me the rights
and it was a one smell like a low instil
lifetime thing probably possibly for him
and definitely for me I was totally
willing and ready to put all my eggs in
that basket but the life lesson not that
I've learned because that implies I did
something wrong but the life lesson I've
gained from it is that the independent
film industry is just too fickle to have
only one thing going on you know it's
too I tried to generate another project
and I got really close to happening
ultimately my heart was only still in co
ji like I couldn't oh I couldn't let go
of that and I'm glad I did that but I
also know now moving forward that I've
got to have like four things I've got to
have at five things you know it's almost
not fair to that project to to put that
much of yourself into it until it's
really ready to go because there's so
many other elements have nothing to do
with you nothing to do with your
persistence or passion or ambition it
just has everything to do with literally
people schedules and money and how
cheaply can something be made or not and
there's so many other things in place
and then you almost put too much it's
kind of when you're in a relationship
with someone you can't expect them to
deliver all of your happiness you kind
of need to find it yourself and and I
sort of expected co ji deliver all my
happiness so I kind of went through this
really dark period where no one wanted
to make it and it was kind of like crap
and I understand why they don't want to
make it it's a darker film it doesn't
wear sedaris is voice on its sleeve
there's no voiceover in it that's not
it's funny I think it's funny but it's
also got this whole other angle to it
that's challenging and devices and and
all of these things and that's what I
wanted it to be so I didn't want to
relent on that so and I didn't want to
relent on some of my creative control
over the project so it just took longer
to get made but I don't think it would
have been is emotionally difficult for
me had I diversified myself more you
know so one of my goals now like in life
is to just sort of like I've got
something that hopefully is going to go
this summer and can't talk it same thing
I can't talk about it yeah but it's a
really exciting project if I would I
could not be happier that goes the
summer but at the same time like I'm
reading a lot of scripts and reading a
lot of books like I'm trying to find
something to do next I'm trying to find
material you have to get excited about
in the meantime so that I'm not throwing
all of my energy into that one thing do
you thrive on that sort of that unknown
area because it's like it's exciting
it's also scary at the same time that
yeah I always said like every time I
open up a script because I'd love to
make something I haven't written you
know that someone else wrote I was there
when I opened a script I like I always
loved the first page no matter what you
do in a minute I want to love it like I
I start out loving it and then usually
it's like my page 10 I'm like okay I'm
gonna you know that's what I've only
ever i'm gonna read so many scripts not
to say that people are sending them to
me but the agency sends them to me and i
read so many and i think in the three
years i've had agents I've only ever
gone in like three times out of maybe
hundreds of script me know it's like cuz
you want to want to love it and it's and
it's hard to find that match I think
that's why I ultimately will end up
writing more writing and directing more
than in just direct but when you do find
that match that it's a David Fincher
talked about it he was like when you
read a script and you love it and you
want to make it that first feeling you
have is what you always have to hold up
but this isn't direct quote but because
if you always have to hold on to that
because the process of getting the film
made is everyone stripping away from
what you initially loved about it you
know and so the way to keep the film
true what your intentions were to try to
just remember that first like spark you
had the first thing you really loved
about it and see your G's definitely
like a testament to that like I I had
there are three or four moments three or
four scenes that I knew I always wanted
to be realized that sort of what kept me
going and so I used those as like the
cornerstones you know I always said even
when it comes down because we're gonna
make the movie way cheaper than it had
been initially budgeted or written to be
and he kind of go okay well these are
the moments that have to deliver these
are the moments we need a half a day
tissue not just a quarter day or these
are the moments or hey the locations got
to be better because it's got to look
like that you know where you have to
fight to make sure those things stay
true greg did you someone like to have
adventure can have the time and money to
make sure every moment stays true to
that but an independent film you're just
like you gotta you gotta shoot it and if
it doesn't happen you just have to keep
on going you know but um but to find to
have a project that has four or five or
three even three or four moments like
that that you feel are going to be that
the the high points of the film and then
make sure they'll stay you stay true to
those no matter what then I think if
it'll work you know as long as
everything's sort of built around that
kind of like an action but you know you
but you not that you should build an
action movie round action sequences but
if you find the you know you want to
make that you want to make sure those
moments are there and I think coz has a
few of those that there where there's
like a spin on a certain character or a
moment something unexpected and those
are the ones I always wanted to build
the movie around I understand that you
did not audition any
lead actors all right yeah my first film
was like all auditions I don't think
either was anyone in the film that did
an audition for it and this time around
because i had my first film to sort of
show for myself I could just kind of go
directly to people I liked and I also
learned i love the casting process i got
love i mean we had to shun some people
ike some of the day players some of the
smaller parts you know but but everyone
whose work I'd seen for me I feel like I
heard a story recently about Chris
Cooper auditioning for a movie and I
thought what would you need Chris Cooper
to audition for like he's this amazing
brilliant actor like what is he gonna
show you in an audition room I think was
feel like a big studio movies the
network or not that the the studio needs
in to audition but still I felt like
he's like one of the greatest actors of
his generation like what would you ask
from him that he hasn't already shown he
can do but for me it was a similar mind
state of that of just like there's these
actors that are just lot like I thought
Corey Stoll just took it took you know
um Midnight in Paris had so many great
performance isn't it and here you had
this guy who really had very little
previous film presence before and stole
the whole movie and just like two scenes
and it was like that feeling was I while
I want to work with that guy like no
matter what and that he wanted to do the
part I'm like what am I gonna have to
you know we talked about it of course I
think you need to have for me I feel
like for especially lead parts and
you've seen someone's work before and
you generally trust them or know what
they're gonna do with it for me a
meeting is more important if you can
talk about the character in a way that's
simpatico then you're going to be able
to work together that's that's more i
love the audition process just with this
movie i felt like if i had the
opportunity to get people like corey or
denis o'hare who I've seen him he's done
every you know is that everything I've
seen him do from like you know small
parts of big studio movies like being a
crazy vampire are true but like he could
do everything so what is it that you
know for me that there's power and
casting in terms of trusting someone's
previous work but like Jonathan I hadn't
seen the lead I hadn't seen him do much
he didn't really have any film credits
to his name he was mostly known from
stage and TV and I'd see him on Glee a
little bit but I didn't really know much
about him and then we met and he had all
these qualities I was looking for just
from our sink down at lunch and we also
got along a lot which when someone's
mean every scene of the movie and
working every minute of every day the
personality plays a huge part
independent
but then he was doing a play downtown
with Alfred Molina where's just the two
of them on stage for two hours and he
was so he was like so good in it and I
just thought well if he can hold his own
against Alfred Molina for two hours
without a break on stage like I'm sure
there's nothing this movie's gonna throw
his way that's gonna be more challenging
than that and um and I think the
instincts were right he was better than
I anticipated like I'm really it's a
thing I'm proudest of most of the movie
is work in it um and I think no I think
it's going to surprise a lot of people
who were familiar with him before but
also introduce them to a lot of people
who weren't familiar with him and and
because he's just really likeable and
has all these sort of great star
qualities I hope that when people see
the film you know that they really love
him in it getting to the part where I'm
sure a lot of directors don't want to be
in how do you tell someone they're not
right from heart that's always a touchy
thing maybe you like them as a person
may be there a brilliant actress yes all
right it's been it's tough it's weird
cuz i I've stayed friends from since we
did a lot of auditioning an easier
practice I've straight friends with some
of the people that we got close to
casting but ultimately didn't and it was
is a touch with them because I loved
them so much in fact the audition one of
things i like about addition is finding
all these great people that might not be
right for the movie but you keep them in
mind for the next one and and for me
it's weird yeah someone can be in it's
hard because it's an argument you always
end up having having half with producers
because they're gonna be like well are
you know our executive types like well
there's this big game and we'd love to
get it said well yeah he's great actor
but he's not right for this not you know
I don't always believe the biggest name
is the best name but to go back to even
the someone who might just not be right
for the party it can be really hard
because just cuz you love someone and
maybe really want it to work with them
doesn't mean it's always gonna gonna fit
right and and it's just I don't know
what it is I Casting I think only is
instinct you know I really really
believe that I mean I think there's
responsibility sometimes financially but
I think if you're making a movie
relatively cheaply you just need to
trust your instincts on it a hundred
percent I really believe that it's it's
hard because I think I've always have
ever argued with financier is the most
thing thing about the most it's casting
because I think at the end of the day if
you don't have any money and you don't
have any time as long as you have a
camera
like a decent-looking space if you have
great actors like your you can have
something amazing and so I've always
fought for independence and casting you
know I always have and of course it
makes maybe a movie more challenging to
sell or whatever but at the end of the
day I can stand by it more you know I
think independent film has become kind
of fueled a lot by the casting process
so you get all these smell movies or
kind of big names or like people who
haven't just like hyped names I don't I
try not to serve into that at all I try
to just cast someone based off what I
think of them but that can create a lot
of opposition to on this moment did on
this moment didn't I think people really
excited everyone kind of knew that
Jonathan was a place to do something
like this and everyone knew Cory was you
know coming it was before any of us had
seen house of cards but house cars has
elevated him so much but we all knew you
was in a place for that and same with
dennis is just these are all those guys
it's been acting for so long and done so
much amazing work that for me I just
didn't even for me it was like it's got
to be him look I just love I love I love
his work so much and I think everyone
loves him in the film you know so it was
there was never any you know we got
lucky but also that's because I passed
on a lot of opportunities to make this
film without casting control so I made
sure the by the time I did get to make
it it was with the understanding that I
was my cast this film the way I wanted
to cast it and I fought for that and had
to wait a long time for that but it
ended up being worth it I don't know if
you saw Shawn Baker's starlet I haven't
seen it yet but I'm dying I know Shawn
and his idea yeah and and he cast one of
the this older lead beside could Johnson
just by seeing her at the YMCA yeah
that's why I heard that it was it was
like him and i know blake the producer
he works with to this is like saw her
and thought she'd be right for it this
is excellent yeah and the chemistry
between she and dreamer just was amazing
so was there anyone like that where you
just kind of saw them in passing and in
or just I've always wanted that you know
you guys hear those stories I've always
wanted that like what I almost did once
in my first film I remember we were
having trouble finding the right person
for the lead and Brian would have to
coming in for his like the last person
to come in not because we want to see
him because he was busy I think she
didn't hurt locker at the time so he
just wasn't even available however one
time I was that like Warner Brothers
commissary and saw someone that I was
like he looks right for the parking
system and cookie my producers let me
just go see if he's would
interested and he ends up being like no
no I'm not an actor but there's one of
those things where like that's like my
dream to just like find someone like
that it's never exactly we just like see
someone and you know that they're right
that's never it hasn't happened to me
yet but I certainly want that but it's
important I think would be great but
what I do try to do the variation is I
try to always even if I see someone that
got a commercial i think was like really
interesting or kind of funny like I try
to look them up or someone who might
have a bit part in a you know I've met a
lot of a lot of actors that way where I
just I see them in like one scene of an
episode of a show and think they're
really interesting and then you bring
them in front and you meet them and then
you end up really liking them and then
sometimes they end up like taking their
careers end up like exploding off
without you having you had any influence
on that but I think it's good to be
aware of that and to try to write those
names down and I have like a huge
running list of just people i think are
interesting that way never haven't
totally ended up casting anyone from it
yet but I've met a lot of great people
that way kinds of filmmakers submit
their films to Sundance every year and
and only a couple hundred are accepted
so if someone came to you and said I
want to get my phone to Sundance what
would you tell them he says you know
great fell the paperwork at the
hundred-dollar check or whatever it is
if it's is it finished or they haven't
made it yet because I would have advised
on both sides okay I think if it wasn't
major what I would say them is I feel
like I'm guessing here but I do feel
like I've gotten to know the Sundance
people over the years and when I look at
the films I do feel like they're people
argued nepotism a lot you know that like
oh it's movies with into Velva I've
never personally seen that you know I've
never seen someone get in just because
in fact I've seen people not get in that
you would think that they should because
of what net because of those nepotism
things I don't think that Trevor and
John run it that way at all i think that
truly program off their God and I mean
every film festivals of business so
there's always that side to it but you
know that's why they have premier
sections and stuff like that but I think
when you look at the competition section
I think they just choose stuff that's
its bold I think they're looking for
something that's you know has some kind
of unique identity to it that's what I
would say to someone like make sure your
film has your don't try to make a movie
that you think would fit the Sundance
mold you know make a movie that is just
of your own and I think next is really
epitomized
and why I forget some of the most
important I mean more most exciting
movies happening there in the next
category because they're just they're
usually really really unique identities
and I think that I mean I would say
there's anyone independent of sunday
it's like just make sure your movie
reflects yourself you know don't try to
even even when comes out some music or
the way it's gonna look like don't don't
try to make it look that way because
another movie did it you know that's
always my least favorite question to
answer someone will be like what what
other movie do you think this movie will
be like you know before you make it and
I'm like cool I'm a kind of think it's
gonna be the way I think I'm gonna make
it i'll have illustrations to show that
but I'm not gonna compare it to it I
think that's the most important thing
and I think when it comes to submissions
I mean you've got to formalize it you've
got to do this a formal submission
process I don't think it you know look
are thousands of films I don't think it
hurts not to pull strings but I don't
think if you have some kind of some way
just to make sure your to get your name
mention not to say that you should show
up I don't believe in you know that kind
of thing I don't think I need to
campaign for your film you know I think
the film will stand it's on on its own
and they do watch the movies and
everything like that but to inquire or
nudge or ask a friend to put in a good
word or whatever I do that all the time
for my friends with other film festivals
I don't think that necessarily
guarantees you or gets you in or
anything like that but it doesn't hurt
to just for someone to remember your
name and have it be set I mean that's
advice I would say a totally independent
of sunday it's just for anything in life
nevertheless you know to be bold and be
persistent you know those things that
exist but I think also the most
important thing I think to submit to
Sundance is to not expect to get in I
don't that's not like it sounds negative
i just think in a positive way I put too
much on myself my friend when my first
film didn't get in it was like rushing
to me and it shouldn't be it shouldn't
be no no festival should determine your
worth that much you know and I'm glad I
had that experience of not getting in
you know it didn't I I've learned to not
let any festival be the indicator of the
quality of your film you know only you
should be the indicator of that you know
and so that's I think what I would tell
people first and foremost but you know
too I always say don't expect it but
plan on it you know if you can shoot
your film a little sooner and have
enough time to edit it to get it in time
like try to do it try to try to do what
you can to have it there
and it be placed in a position where it
could be accepted you know um also trust
that they are used to seeing rough cuts
they saw really rough cut of my film
that was really uncomfortable about it
but they that's their job is to see the
see what the film is guns are going to
become you know festival programmers see
rough versions of films all the time and
my initial on my first film I was like
it needs to be totally finished and it
needs to be sound mix and everything you
need to know there needs to be no room
for what they think but I realized that
it's actually okay like they're they're
really tuned to that to the filmmaking
process in the post-production process
and make sure you're submitting
something you can stand behind you know
that to me feels like like if you never
get a chance to people play their films
at festival sometimes I mean like well
it's still a work in progress and I was
like no way I need to like brenton of
course you always want to make changes
to your film that I played it played my
film at the cut at Sundance which it
very little time to finish I played that
there with the assumption I'll never get
to touch again and financially I
probably won't but you know I had to be
okay with that what other people I know
that like well I'm still thinking about
doing this and tweaking this and like
you probably shouldn't be charging
people not even see your film then
that's just that's just my opinion you
know I mean everyone runs a different
way but in terms of getting in that's
what I think it's a plan for it put your
best foot forward you know submit it
formally try to inquire if you can if
you know someone who knows a programmer
just you know say hey put in a good word
for me I I would say just to do that
just to create awareness of the project
but having said that I night program for
festivals before not some dance but I
real i watch everything every festival
program I know they do watch things
there's always a sort of inks well they
will they really watch it or not and
they will because that I feel like the
true festival programmer you know when
you meet the people who've been doing it
their whole lives what they want they
want like I said when I read the script
the first time I want to like when they
put in a movie I think they always want
to love it they want to discover that
movie that like someone made in their
backyard in Tennessee that's like
unheard of and unparalleled and totally
unique and creative like that's what
their desire is for and so I think you
want you want to keep that in mind that
they're not sitting I've rarely seen a
festival programmer that's a
you know where usually they have that
optimism of wanting to find something
great in the middle of thousands of
thousands of movies and most of those
thousands of movies aren't you know it's
strange you think like God who made
twelve thousand movies you think I think
a lot of times they're really Rock you
know sometimes the movies are really
rough and maybe don't aren't unique
enough but you know it's I do think
everything does get considered and do
you think a lot of filmmakers get
overzealous and they put their first
feature in something thinking that it's
going to work or I mean oh yeah you I'm
gonna think you make it of course I mean
I made my first movie being like it's
gonna play at Sundance and then it's
gonna I gotta hit to make my next film I
mean you kind of have to have that like
vision for yourself but at the same time
it's not they shouldn't run I shouldn't
dictate everything and I think of course
if we can get your 1st one to play their
you absolutely should I would play
anything I could there um so I certainly
think you should always aim the highest
you can but also not I think what
happens then you put so much expectation
on it so much value on the festival that
then if you don't and I see this happen
to me briefly and I've seen it happen to
a lot of people that if you don't get in
then you feel like it's an indicative of
your worth you know it's like if you
don't do well on the SATs it makes you
feel like you're done when the st's
don't really of course you know that I
mean they don't have it it's kind of the
same feeling it should it shouldn't
dictate that at all because they see so
many films and ultimately they have an
mo they have a certain amount of films
certain program a certain some movies
with one storyline and they want
different storyline you know they have
their own goals that are separate from
your own and and having said that too if
you do get in and then your movie
doesn't blow up there you know it's like
if your movie doesn't become about the
big overnight sales like my movie wasn't
it's gonna sell we're gonna get
distribution I'm really happy about it
people are gonna get a chance to see it
it's exactly what I expected the path to
go down but of course you go to the
festival hoping I'm going to be you know
beasts or I'm going to be fruitvale or
I'm going to be whatever it might be you
want to be like that breakout but the
but only one movie or two movies every
year got to be that breakout so it's
unfair for you to put yourself in that
expectation to say well if I don't break
out from this and if our people knocking
my door to make the next film like it's
it's that's unreasonable to put on two
ND you can't gauge what is gonna hit a
certain audience a certain time so
anyways I guess my
goal is by whole thing I'm going off on
tangents but my whole feeling about it
is is that you can't expect the industry
now that I mean the festival industry or
the industry to like hand you anything
just because you made your first film or
even just because you made your second
film or even just cuz you made your
third like I know if anything I've
learned along the way is it's like it's
not necessarily gonna get easier you
have to keep on proving yourself and you
have to keep on fighting for yourself
sure some people get their movie blows
up and then they get all the
opportunities handed to them but that's
one out of every you know 200-300
filmmakers you know and so it doesn't
mean that I'm going to stop making films
just because one movie didn't do as well
or as well as another movie or something
you know I think that you can't you just
can't expect you can hope I guess plant
you know it's like you can plan for
Sunday's but don't expect it you can
plan for success but don't expect
success see if I think that that's like
the best advice and not you put too much
pressure on yourself do you think in
some sense it almost gets harder because
people love discovering new things and
they want to embrace it and they want to
be the first jalan and then once
something's already established then the
peanut gallery comes out whether it's
from jealousy or just oh I could have
done a better job or whatever only doing
something it's almost harder in some
sense some ways it gets harder some ways
it gets easier you know like I said like
casting got easier because I could get
access to these amazing actors they love
because they had a film to show for
myself so they could watch and be like
okay it takes away some risk for them
they can say I liked his first movie so
yeah but in other ways it gets a lot
harder because there isn't you're not a
blank slate anymore some people can't
people can't project how they think
you're going to be fine answers can for
Jenna they can see your film and then I
can say well the first one didn't really
make that much money and yeah I got
awards but didn't how many people sigh
you know whatever they can use that is
but i think the true people are going to
see potential you know the true people
who you want to collaborate with will
see what you were trying to do and
whether you achieved it or not and see
what how you might bring that into the
next film and grow from it um I hope
people see that but yeah I can get in
some ways it does get absolutely harder
it took longer for me to make my second
film than my first
and we made it cheaper so you know it
wasn't necessarily money it's just the
nature of how challenging is the
material how did some hair to notify you
I got a call but I had made that I made
the film we you know we were I think I
think Trevor said this when he
introduced the film publicly that I
think we were the loo the only movie to
the no movie has ever wrapped shooting
in November and played the festival in
January so we had a really fast
post-production process I'm my own
editor I run post on my movie so I was
able to pull it off you know but it was
one of those things where we submitted a
rough cotton I didn't have to wait that
long because they were having to lock
their schedule I was just lucky they
even were able to watch it still you
know cuz they were still watching a
handful of straggling films that were
coming in and I was able to get get a
rough version of my movie in so i didn't
i didn't have to wait i had to wait less
than a week but still when I got the
call it was if it were felt really good
was that I did not knowing what it felt
like to not get in which hit me too hard
the first time that this time around I
told myself I was like I'm just
submitting because i put the film I knew
I was innocent in the film for a year I
knew I tried other festivals if we if we
add even when we were shooting the film
I didn't think we were going to get a
chance to even place on pants cuz I just
think the timing would work out um and
so for me when I found out that there
would still be enough time for me to put
a rough edit together for them to screen
I thought I'm submitting for myself I'm
not submitting for even the movie I'm
just submitting to know I did my best in
the time I had I didn't sleep for a week
and I got an edit to get you know that
kind of thing I I did my best in that
time so I at the end of the day I
couldn't feel like well maybe what if
you know that that feeling you know I
didn't I wouldn't regret not trying for
it so ultimately submitting the movie
for me it felt more cathartic and I was
I was expecting to not get in a lot of
ways um and so getting in felt really
good and the call came from Trevor who
you know he saved kind of saved my first
film you know all the festivals all the
major festivals had passed on it and he
was running sinnott Vegas at the same
time he was running Sundance and so he
had seen it at Sundance because they had
really considered it and one of the
strangest moments for me and talking
about Sundance was when John Cooper
introduced the prayer of co ji you know
he talked about how it still haunted him
to no
program easier practice which was like
really humbling and really nice to hear
and a lot of ways to know that they
really did you know consider it and mine
was one of those like we were talking
about before mine was a totally blind
submission I didn't know anyone in the
festa world at all in my first film so
to hear i got that close is is really
overwhelming and and and so getting the
call from trevor who's been one of the
most supportive people to me it just
meant a lot i had like the weight of
like years on it you know sort of had
the weight of no one wanting this film
to get made it's in some strange way you
know you don't want to look to the
festival to give you validation but what
the one thing it does nice it doesn't
give you personal validation it gives
I'll addition to everyone else you know
for everyone else is a shorthand it's
kind of like the same way the Spirit
Awards was it's like for me like winning
awards and stuff that doesn't really
mean anything to me personally but what
it means is something for the movie and
it means something for like my ability
to keep on making movies because it's
shorthand for people so people like well
how do you really like it that much but
I played Sundance so there must be
something greater good about it you know
people use it as like a litmus test for
better or worse it's it's one of the
advantages of it so um for me it was it
felt really good I mean it was really
and also like I was at the very tail end
of working every day because we went it
was like we were financed in August we
prepped in September we shot in October
and part of November I cut it in
november we found out we got it in late
november you know as one of those things
where it was like I didn't sleep and
then it was like I had to cut that I had
like a less than a month the lock
picture and then post and the two days
later we premiered the movie so it was
literally one long stream of like five
months four months of just a non-stop
work every day of the week so it was
sort of a culmination of that and all
that sort of impacts with me getting the
sickest i've been maybe in my entire
life of not at least a decade when in
sunday's cuz like my body just like shut
down from all the hard work but it was
but it was really it was new it was a it
was a great feeling and it you know it
was really nice to have their support it
was so your first two films easier with
practice and co ji are adapted works
yeah Brady producers or filmmakers out
there are interested in optioning and
adapting an author's work how how do we
go about it what are some of the first
steps the first steps is usually if you
go to the author's site you can find
agent information or contact so that
this is assuming if you're totally
independent you don't have an agent you
don't have manager no one that can sort
of inquire these things for you um
usually you want to look and see who
their reps are usually you can find that
online like that's usually pretty easy
um and if they have a Los Angeles like a
talent then you probably want to call
them first because they're gonna be
people you don't want to talk to about
film rights find out where the rights
are first and foremost you know and then
from there what it really first of all
you need to get a lawyer at some point
on it like that's the most important
thing because I I tried to do it without
a lawyer once it was just wrong like
it's just we just will always want you
never want to sign anything I'm led by
anything that where you're putting money
into it or there's some kind of
long-term agreement without a lawyer
you're looking at over like you just
everyone knows someone who's a lawyer
who can probably you know super I'm not
saying you have to pay thousands and
thousands for a fancy lawyer but you
definitely don't want to sign an
agreement with a writer that you're
going to put time and money investment
into writing a script and maybe making
to a movie unless someone's approved
this initial agreement first um because
those things can come back to haunt you
they never have for me it's always
worked out well but I know and I've
heard stories and it can happen you just
want a lawyer that's the no matter what
you want one um but you know you want to
see how open they are saying yes you
want to see how how much money it's
going to cost what you know typically I
find that where you want you want to be
able to talk to the author you know you
want to be able to be sincere with your
intention of what you want to do when
your work and communicate that to them
you know so it's you know for Davey
rothbard that the first first movie was
based on he was really interested in
film and this was a magazine article
hero but it was part of his life and
getting in touch with him is a little
bit easier but I also went through like
a friend who was at an agency so that I
didn't have any agents but I had a
friend call who was working at an agency
so it seemed a little bit more formal
just to get into the door you know you
want to try to pull any kind of tricks
like that you can i'm not lying to
people or anything but just if you have
a friend with any kind of access like
that or a frame
who works at an agency or someone who
can do you a favor and make at least an
initial call I don't need to say they're
repping you but you know just always try
to find the any kind of back channels in
but then in addition to that try to get
in touch with the author you know try to
not directly I think try to do the
formal channels first you know that's
what you always want to do you want to
be respectful first and if they put you
in touch so like Davies agent put me in
touch with him and we got on the phone I
told him why I wanted to make this into
a film and why I liked the story and um
and he said yes and there was somebody
negotiated but you know it was it was it
was relatively reasonable you know I'm
you can you can make things work with
people obviously with David and that
this was from a published work from you
know it wasn't a magazine article it was
a very popular book it was it was a
little bit more it was way more
complicated and just by sheer nature a
little bit more costly because you're
setting precedent and you're doing
things like that so it was it was
difficult in a lot of ways even though
everyone you know David wanted me to do
it and I want to do it they're still
agents and there's still contracts and
there's still things of just naturally
they're always it's always complicated
even when everyone's amicable is always
a lot because you're figuring things out
and this is you think about David and
his rights and it was really important
to me and I always advocated for this
too is like I just wanted this story I
did well you know when he writes both
people they write about their own life
experiences so you think about how
complicated those legal rights have to
be to make sure that you're not
optioning they of course can't happen to
give you the option to all of their life
you know it's only this one piece you
know and so it's oh it's you can just
get complicated depending on what the
nature of it is but I think it's about
you know being realistic knowing the
writer who's adopted them before adapted
them before but also being ambitious and
I everyone was telling me know about
David everyone was saying he doesn't say
yes this is too it's too big you don't
have the money mo you know everyone's
saying all of those things I still went
for it and still worked out so I would
never say any of this to deter someone
you know but I'd also say that like hey
if you want to join if you want the
stronger sure book like know that John
Grisham has a history of you know
selling his rights for a lot of money
and maybe there's something really
specific for me there was something
really specific and particular about the
story that I thought would fit David
Sensibility so I felt that so many of
you did someone really famous but you
feel there's something really
think about the way you're approaching
the project I say still go for it you
know but obviously if you like a
courtroom thriller from John Grisham
it's you know it's it be realistic about
it but also be ambitious and even if
that writer you reach out to let's say
it's like an e-book or something they
don't have any representation you'll
make sure that on their side to that
they have lawyers make sure everyone's
happy and be upfront and better to
figure out if there's many conflicts
before then when you're you've already
finished a film and then suddenly
someone has a problem with it you know
even want to get that stuff out of the
way right away then you know a lot of
writers will though sometimes get free
options are really cheap options for
just like a year and then you can update
it later you know there's a lot of ways
to go about getting access to material
what about follow up Kyle like if you
write to someone or contact their people
and you don't hear back or what if you
hear a no is it is it then bad form to
then go back again and try to push I
don't think so i think it does always
matter it being you have to know that
it's their job to say no you know it's
an agent's job to say to say no they're
protecting their client and they
probably get a lot of requests so you
have to be respectful of them but
persistent but also then at that point
you know for me you know his
representation who've been incredibly
supportive of the project I don't have a
single bad thing to say about their look
it's this policy to say no we really
appreciate it but he said no to film
projects and for me at that point I was
like well this is different and I want
to communicate to him how this was
different but you know I had a finished
film and so I just went to one of his
book readings and handed him a copy of
the film I didn't try to pitch him
myself there anything I mean he was Davy
Rothbart was of this american life
colleague of his they knew each other
and so i could be like hey I made this
movie about Davey Roth bar if you like
and I'd like to talk to you you know and
I saw it for me it's it's just always
about staying respectful and knowing why
people especially if the author is more
well known what no know why they have a
system around them you know and if and
trust that but also trust your instincts
if you feel like I just need a chance to
talk to them or you know sometimes
that's where I find if you write a
letter you know if you write like a
personal letter usually it's the
representations imperative to at least
pass that letter on you know they
usually won't it'll take a really
cynical agent
to tear up a letter you know what I mean
and not pass it on if you mean it
sincerely so you know it's less about
getting an answer and more about doing
enough that makes you feel like you know
once i had to David the copy of the
movie for me that was my line that was
like as far as I would go with it
invited I will i sent a letter through
his representation and i gave him a copy
of my film that a reading of his at that
point moving on if I never heard from
him I would have achieved peace with it
you know that I felt like that was
enough and I did if I got to know or
never even heard anything for me I
pushed enough so I think just knowing
when when you pushed enough is important
well what is that line between polite
persistence and then just being
obnoxious pushy what's that doing the
great in the radio at paranoid android
that radiohead song he says ambition
makes you look pretty ugly you know it's
one of those things it's like yeah you
can I think you just need to know I
think you need to just learn how to read
people and and know when it's too i
don't know where that is its instincts
maybe sometimes I've been on the other
side of it you know in the wrong side of
it you know I I try to you know there's
it's a fine line between ugly ambition
and persistence and I think it's just
kidding just trusting your own gut any
situations probably different I think so
yeah so you said finding money for co ji
was what a three year it was probably
about three years I had an idealism that
I write the script and it'd be a david
sedaris thing the first and probably
only put david sedaris project and my
thing was so okay even though it's all
dark an offbeat people are gonna want to
make it you know people are gonna make
this and make it at a higher end indie
budget la folie know like a few million
and it was night it was a little naive
on my aunt to think that you know i was
putting a lot of restrictions on it you
know i think when you're going for money
you need to know what how willing how
where are your priorities for me my
priority wasn't controlling the material
keeping the script the same and being
able to decide on having you know the
final say on casting like those are the
kind of things then that are going to
push
investors away not to say that if I
embraced all those things anyone were
jumped on board ultimately I'm making a
movie that was dealing with religious
things theme sexuality you know stuff
that isn't necessarily yeah every time I
see him an independent film like I don't
know how they got it financed and I mean
I always feel it as a compliment you
know especially only see ones made like
damn like how did that happen I think
every single film finds its own way and
usually that way is totally different
than the previous way you know i mean
this this was it was just a long process
of really getting a lot of no's at one
point i think i calculated it was like
it sorry once i got like over like 150
knows or so i just i stopped counting
like I kept a running chart and when it
was like hit that many of people like
finance ears or producers or company's
production companies had passed on it
then I just like stopped keeping a
number tally cuz i got a little
depressing you know i feel like i have a
thick skin but i think it's okay for
anyone to feel like 150 rejections on
the same script is a little it could be
a little nine dumbing you know but um it
was you know but it was about I thought
the system would sort of serve me a
little better like I thought well I made
my first film and people saw it and
people liked it and now I've written the
script and it's a well-known author and
I have agents and it's gonna it'll it'll
come together in the way it should and
it was kind of wrong for me to feel that
way because ultimately it came together
through whatever resources I sort of
engaged and build and so I had support
from you know film independent that I
had on my own that I had built over over
the years and they I got brought into a
program where i met a producer who came
on board the bra financing you know so
it was one of those things ended up
being through my own path and not see it
as a anything negative towards the
agency route but just to say that like
at no point should you ever just sort of
be like okay well now i have reps and
they're gonna get it all taken care of
like you know at the end of the day
you're only you're always responsible
for yourself and I think financing is no
different um just about always staying
on top of anyone you know anyone who
might know someone with money and just
always staying persistent on it and keep
on pushing and keep on pushing because
it's gonna everyone's gonna say no I
mean rarely do what I really ever heard
of a story where someone was like I was
realize that the script on people liked
it we got a baby
I get that maybe happens with genre
films but I don't think it ever happens
with a drama or comedy or especially not
a dark comedy no well this is a weird
question but I understand there's a few
masturbation scenes there well easier to
practice had a lot that made it really
difficult this one only has one I told
myself I was gonna put it but each other
oh ma it's definitely r-rated stuff
there's stuff that's even stranger than
masturbation things in some ways I think
it's even edgier than my first edgier
for me people use the word had to
describe sex but it's not there's no
nudity there's no sex in it but there's
like uncomfortable moments in it there's
stuff that I'm like okay I hope they're
memorable because it's cut their
unexpected turns in it but it's also got
it takes a pretty clean you know it also
deals with religious themes a lot not
until sort of second half of the film
but you know that makes people work
nervous and I it doesn't pop in fact I
think it's really respectful I had no
agenda with the religious approach in at
all but each other deals with that and
it did like I said before didn't wear
sedaris is voice on its sleeve I hope
it's like in his spirit but isn't his it
doesn't take any of his jokes and put
the meat Ely on screen it doesn't
deliver that much on sort of the wish
fulfillment of unfortunately David
Sedaris fans have really liked it and
got what we were going 404 preciated
that we didn't just take it throw it up
on screen that you know we really put it
through a process and then I made in my
own it seems like most of his fans
appreciate that um but it made it hard
for people to understand exactly what
the movie was gonna be like um and I
would imagine my next film will probably
just as hard know to get to get going so
did you entertain crowd funding for part
of the budget I thought about it um I
felt I feel too successful I really
believe in crowdfunding in a lot of ways
I feel for it to be most successful you
need to have the support of everyone
involved and for me David's been in
court like beyond supportive like
overwhelmingly supportive of the project
but he wasn't a producer on the film he
you know he would say the Sioux he's up
he wasn't interested in the process he
wanted to let me go make it and I sort
of felt to run a successful
crowdsourcing campaign for it it would
have needed his involvement because I
felt it would have been sort of dissing
genuine to be the way to run a
successful campaign would have been like
hey stairs fans you want to see a
sedaris movie and it felt what is sort
of I didn't feel comfortable
skin here maybe he would have helped me
had done a video I'm not sure but I it
felt wrong to ask him you know for me
and I felt without his support it felt
sort of wrong to run a campaign for it
now that there's a finished film that we
you know we've closed distribution so I
bet if i was doing a self distribution i
would consider it now that there's a
finished film and now that i have
interviews with david elements i can use
with the permission of course but but I
feel like it's each each projects its
own and some projects are meant to be
crowd funded and this one just wasn't
wasn't one of them I didn't feel like I
can engage the community in the right
way and also we had some actors attached
but they ended up not being the actors
in the final film and I felt like we
would have needed to utilize them but I
felt uncomfortable with that because I
didn't have a working relationship with
them yet and they were you know slightly
bigger names that would ended up in the
movie just by the nature of who have at
the time I cast them they weren't bigger
names and they got bigger names I got
too busy be in the film and I ended up
with a cast I could have only dreamed of
having anyway so I'm thrilled about that
but it felt strange to bring them
involved it just didn't feel like I
could do it the right way and I feel
like when they look at the really
successful crowd crowd campaigns sure
there's some outliers that go into the
three and four hundred thousand dollars
but I really feel like the most
ambitious you really should get you know
is it to expect is at the most you know
100 you know I feel like even the
canyons I think they ended up going to
like 130 but you're Paul Schrader at
Bret Easton Ellis who each have massive
loyal decades-long fan bases and even
then they pushed a lot on that campaign
and you know they had which is
incredible amount of money but that
still wasn't enough for me to make the
film so I also felt uncomfortable going
out there and mainly give me a hundred
thousand dollars and maybe I'll be able
to find the other however much we need
it it just felt wrong for this project
but i hope i can do something one day
that i can make cheaply enough you know
this movie had to be shot on location it
had 30 speaking parts it had you know a
different location every day all
exteriors just had things that naturally
made it expensive and but i hope to do
something if I did something small if I
did a movie I could shoot on my own with
minimal crew and minimal okay
here in Los Angeles i would i would
totally consider doing crowd sourcing
that way Kyle how many filmmakers at
Sundance had publicists and it's a
necessary thing most filmmakers and you
had publicists there um I think everyone
in competition did and probably most the
film's next I mean I think of your
playing you have to know the festival
you're playing at you know I think if
you're playing at a big festering Sunday
this is the second arguably the second
biggest film festival in the world if
you have an opportunity to play there
like it's find a way to get a publicist
I mean it's like you know you can get
someone you can find people to work to
work you know relatively cheaply but
it's going to take some money your job
of playing at a festival you ask
yourself okay you know what you serve
the festival you provide them content to
play what does the festival provide you
well it provides you a platform a for
people to get to see your film but
theoretically there's so many forms of
independent distribution and
distribution that let's put that aside
for a second really the festival's
primary purpose for you is the publicity
you get the write-ups you get the
reviews you get all of that and you and
that's your main reason for playing
their customers so much money to get to
a festival so much money to get a film
to a festival at that point the few
thousand dollars plus you know you might
have to set aside to get a good
publicist on board to me comparatively
cost wise seems imperative granted if
you're playing a smaller festival you
know you're playing in a smaller city
without as much press coverage most
small film festivals have a great press
team they usually bring in press teens
from New York or LA and they do the
press for the film's I'm granted their
their motivation is to publicity for the
festival but they usually can get you
pretty good coverage and it just spends
i would say it depends on how many
movies are really at the festival how
big of a festival is it is it your world
premiere is it you know these are all
the questions you kind of have to ask
because there's a way to do it yourself
um but I also think there's so many
other things you have to focus on
sometimes it's really nice to be able to
have someone worrying about that sign
it's also I find where policies become
the most useful is they're knowledgeable
about like the critic so they're
knowledgeable at variety there's three
critics there let's say or something
then they know they'll say well I think
this one is going to appreciate your
movie the best because I had this other
movie that was kind of like
it and he really liked it and it really
helped us so I'm gonna make sure he can
go like you know think about that on
your own you're trying to get ready for
the festival you're trying to get
materials when you're trying to get like
Castro any travel ready and then you're
going to have to do research on which
critics and then you don't have the
influence to caller ID and say hey can
this guy removing my film not to say
that publicists always have that
influence and I'm just using variety cuz
it's just broaden easy to recognize I've
never had that experience specifically
with them they've always been great to
me but it's into my phones but you know
I think it's just it's someone that can
help navigate it especially if you never
have before so I really strongly
encourage and I think of all festival
expenses it's probably one of the most
born to consider but if you're playing a
smaller regional festival you'll
probably be okay because usually you
know you'll have some press there and
mostly local press and they're gonna
want they're gonna want to seek you out
you know they're gonna want they're
gonna on their end you know they don't
there's maybe 15 movies in the festival
or 20 as opposed to 200 so it's each
situation as its own but it's definitely
something I encourage on the on the
bigger festivals let's say though that
there's just no option of having a
publicist and it's a smaller festival
and you're just getting your toe in the
water what are some DIY you know
do-it-yourself kind of your own
publicist I think the good thing is the
internet helps to this a lot I think
look at the I've done this in the past
to with some smaller festivals is look
at the look at people who have covered
in the past get the usually you can get
the press list for the festival if
you're going to be doing it yourself so
they can tell you who's gonna be there
you know put together your own press
blast even if you have to you know like
if you you know create an email address
that says whatever co ji movie doc you
know at whatever you know creating email
address and i put together just you mean
i think everyone knows what not a press
release but like a screening blast just
you know has your poster your screening
times a little description of the movie
the cast and a contact and then you send
that to everyone on the list like that's
what your publicist is going to do first
and foremost to just create awareness
and also work with their publicity
office a lot like let them know like
know what the anecdotes of your story
are like what is the narrative behind
your story that people are going to want
to hear obviously with this film people
want to hear how it's how did it sedaris
how did you get the rights and and
that's the story that i'll probably
still tell plenty plenty plenty of times
I hadn't meet
you know I know that or I know what what
is what is in your film it's specific to
press so my film has K elements I'm gay
okay so that opens up game press or do
you have a certain minority that there's
you know a lot of festivals usually have
like a Latino you know press presence
and they're looking they want to find
someone who's either you know I have I'm
my parents are Cuban immigrants so that
usually is then a story that way so you
kind of just need to be aware of what
are the what are the strengths of your
film that might appeal to specific press
and get involved with the with the
festival's press offices and ask them
what you can do and and make yourself
known I find out what the internet that
I feel like the canvassing is less
important I feel like an even four years
ago like the getting postcards and
putting them all up around town and
posters I feel like that used to be the
most important thing to do it at Film
Festival now I don't really know at
least at Sundance I don't really almost
no one did that you know and we had like
some postcards in a couple posters but
it just depends on I feel like the
program guide and people will look
things up on the internet you know
having a nice well maintained facebook
page i feel is even more important than
putting up posters all around town
someone might disagree with me on that
but lately i found that that that seems
to be more important have you ever done
your own social media i do my own social
media oh yeah definitely I mean we know
are you obsessive about checking Twitter
um yeah I'm not nearly as good with
Twitter as I should be I've been running
the facebook page more because I feel
like I can I should be better about
Twitter because that's obviously has a
little bit more exposure sometimes but
facebook i get more how to create it
like i got how to integrate images more
i got how to make it look better right i
have a have a relationship with the guy
who runs sedaris is page so we can run
links to that and get attention that way
where it's like twitter we don't
necessarily have that kind of like and i
also don't my own personal twitter i
don't update that much i'm really bad
with this i should be better with
twitter but the facebook one I run a lot
and I I just try to make sure to keep
content on it you know at least twice a
week put something up you know even if
it's just a update or something you know
so that people don't forget about it and
keep it going but I haven't been able
with the festival is one thing and the
festival sunday has generated a lot of
its own press but now I'm getting into a
little bit more of the DIY mode which is
like okay we have our distribution
coming up I know I have to be
responsible for a lot of awareness of
home so I need to start getting out
there a lot more so aside from your
movies what is the brand of Kyle because
you know you see them know once you get
to a certain level you become you know
Tom Inc you don't come to all this ever
think so what's the brand of Kyle
because you do have to throw a person
you have to think about it you do and I
don't I mean I would be like I ideal
world like I would just like keep on
making movies and no one would even know
what I would look like but I also know
nowadays especially with the internet
and independent film primarily being
director fueled you know there's movies
that sunday it's with big-name stars in
them and their press is still just want
to talk to the director it's kind of
surreal it's only an undependable
doesn't really work that way um but I
definitely thought about it and
obviously there's a lot of connective
tissue between my first and second film
like they're both based on like memoir
essays they're both This American Life
riders named David they both deal with
like themes of sexuality i think the
movies are really different I think co
ji is a lot funnier it's a lot faster
the pacing is really different but i
also don't necessarily want to continue
down that path you know the next thing
I'm involved with is a true life story
but it's not memoir based really it's
like an actual like historical event so
it's a place in specific period it's
different it's really different it's a
lot colder it's more of drama but um
obviously I making two films that are
generally similar I don't mind sort of
being put in that place but I also hope
to be able to break out with it and
maybe do something a little more genre
or something a little different but I
guess I would love for my brand to be a
non-brand you know that's why I like
I've always respected Angley like even
when he's made you know he's made his
fair share of like not his great movies
but he's always made something grape
he's always being something so wildly
different than before that I really
respect that like I'd love to have that
opportunity but we'll see either way the
way I think about it the way I think
about myself is I would love an
opportunity to make something on a
bigger scale and that happens that's
great but as far as I'm concerned the
path I'm continuing down is still an
independent one still low budget one I
think you have to be responsible to make
movies cheaply nowadays because if
you're not doing a cheaply someone else
will and so I just try to always still
think of things smaller I just think
it's did that way i can if i need to you
know i hope i can go into a project that
has financing already i don't have to do
all that but if i do have to go down
that path again then I'm prepared to and
I have projects that are prepared to be
made you know on a scalable budget